so not being garyvee how can I sort of
inspire people to around me to work on
their excuses by do you know it's funny
I long before I was Gary Vee this is
what I was doing for my high school
friends who were doing stupid things
like drugs and alcohol or driving drunk
because they wanted to act cool in front
of somebody this is just about self
esteem it's so simple it's almost overly
emotional for me this is about self
esteem the way I choose to do it and you
know this is how I do it as I go
directly at it if you you can every one
of us can think of somebody we care
about right now that's just not doing it
right and all you have to do is sit them
down and tell them they're not doing it
right
but we don't want to do that because
we'd rather not short-term hurt their
feelings
and let them fail long-term which is
remarkably crazy if you give up about
somebody so what can you do is not Gary
Vee have the actual conversation and
tell your sister your mom your uncle
your aunt your child your best friend
the next time they come up with an
excuse that it's a excuse the reason I
say the thing that if there's anybody
that ever looked like you that made it
then there's no excuse is because I
believe it you know it's really hard
here in our argument and that your
friend tells you that's great Gary but
both my parents were alcoholics and that
really to me up right now you're on the
defense that's a good first punch by
them I'm like cool we don't need to use
me if anybody has ever been successful
that had two alcoholic parents which by
the way I know of three well then now
what's your Excuse Karen we are just so
interested in blaming everybody else and
excuses cuz we don't want to take on
responsibility and somewhere a long time
ago I went completely I only take I do
you know I think everything is my fault
like all of it like I think it's weirdly
cloudy outside right now and not nice
out my fault
like his scar my fault like I just
default into my fault
and everybody tries to do everything
else the other way and let me tell you
how good life becomes when you take on
responsibility it gets real good uh some
of you and there's a lot of beautiful me
you know why I keep bringing up the last
scene of eight mile the Eminem movie how
many people have seen that movie great
the last scene they go into the battle
he makes fun of himself the whole time
because it leaves the other person with
nothing the leverage is in being
accountable of everything the leverage
is exposing your weaknesses I proudly
talk about passing on uber twice being a
DNF student you know I proudly talk
about my shortcomings right
I can't wait for more bad things to
happen I mean it because I will talk
about them because what you're so
imperfect q right so how do you do it
you have the conversation and you
realize that you're doing a disservice
to the people you love the most by
holding your mouth shut because you're
not willing to deal with the short-term
conflict
[Applause]
[Music]